it is actually something of a surprise
they they you know a lot of people
thought they might raise interest rates
this time around but what with the new
variant uh coming to the uk uh in the
last few days that had that kind of you
know diminished that expectation they've
raised interest rates they were doubt
they were down at 0.1 they are now
0.25
so it's up by 0.15 15 basis points uh as
they call it i haven't yet seen the
minutes because they are literally just
uh being published uh right now um the
vote was eight one so you have the
monetary policy committee and it's their
job there's nine people on the monetary
policy committee it's their job each
time they have a meeting it's more or
less each month to decide what to do
with interest rates and indeed with
monetary policies so remember we've got
quantitative easing going on almost 9
billion pounds worth of money being
electronically printed and pumped into
the economy well this time around
people thought in the city it may be 50
50 maybe a little bit less i wasn't
entirely sure they were going to do this
because of omicron because of the fears
of what's happening uh to activity
around the economy but they have gone
for it they've raised interest rates
it's the first time obviously uh since
uh during the post-brexit period where
they started to increase them off 0.25
percent and it's a big moment and why
are they doing this it's because of the
news we had yesterday inflation uh up
above five percent obviously it's their
job to try to keep inflation as close as
possible to two percent it's now way
above its target the highest we've had
in a decade and they've decided uh to
take that decision um eight one uh was
the votes on the monetary policy
committee so eight people voting for
that increase one person voting against
uh and we'll bring you more detail on
precisely how that broke down and what
they've said about inflation as it comes
in but very unusual for them to do this
in december actually the first increase
as far as i can remember that we've had
in december since the creation of the
monetary policy committee usually they
do it not right ahead of christmas but a
big moment the start in what may be a
series of increase increases in interest
rates pushing up the cost of borrowing
for families across the country also
increasing the benefits of saving
in the face of inflation being very high
indeed